there we are there we are oh
hello
my people of the internet I hope you
guys if you are here uh have either read
the three writing problem books or seen
the episodes because okay look I'll say
I'll say this just to start off I feel
like this show
is for people that have read the books
or know what they're getting into I
think that especially in America and the
West all of our television is very
Americanized this is a very different
thing
um there's gonna be 30 episodes I'm
pretty sure it's just book one so it's
very very
slow and gradual and it builds up
because it's basically the entire book
and doesn't seem like they're cutting
anything it's like the whole book like
every conversation uh every scene so
I've watched the first four episodes I
really enjoy the first first first four
episodes I was saying earlier that I
think this show is a show that's
absolutely 100 made for people that have
read the book and not necessarily like a
new audience I don't really see people
that don't really know what they're
getting into watching this show really
but if you love The Three body problem
and you love the concepts and you've if
you've read the book or you just like
know of what happens I think you can get
into it because it's not typically when
we see adaptations
one thing that's always true in all
adaptations is they skip over a lot of
things they condense plot lines they
combine characters together to Aid in
Simplicity
um here there's pretty much none of that
it seems like all the minor characters
are there
um basically every conversation
from the book is present so far there
are a few things that are being told out
of order and there is one particular
moment that seems to have been emitted
but it it could be coming back later so
we'll see about that but um I also heard
that that particular Moment In the book
is also censored in the Chinese version
of the book
um and I don't want to give it away and
spoil it in case people haven't read the
book but um there's a particular scene
that apparently is not in the Chinese
version of the book and it takes place
in the beginning of the American version
at least and it doesn't seem to be a
part of this show yet but it could
happen in a flashback but I feel like if
it's censored in the book then it's
probably going to be censored of the
show too so we'll see about that
um
the first episode I think does a really
good job
um of building the tension and making
you uncertain it's the same feeling that
I got reading the book
um and the show is doing is interesting
because it's reminding me of the feeling
that I had when I read the first book
because I didn't know what it was about
um I uh just spoiler alert like minor
spoiler like the whole thing it's about
there's
aliens aliens are happening but um so I
didn't know that like going into the
first
reading the book at first and so it was
curious seeing like all the layers
slowly be unveiled like what is really
going on there is there seems to be like
this mystery that's like written into
the core of reality itself like physics
isn't working right so that like like
our fundamental understanding of Nature
and how everything interacts with each
other it doesn't seem it doesn't seem to
be working at all and that's that's that
itself is is very very scary I mean in
the first episode we get the character
talking about how
over the last several decades when it
comes to you know theoretical physics
and you know the higher forms of science
the theories have are becoming less and
less simplistic and more and more vague
it's like our understanding is
increasing in a way but it's also
almost like we're hitting um it's almost
like we're hitting a wall as well
so um that's very very interesting
and very scary to think that like we can
try so hard and we can continue to
develop so far but then like eventually
we just hit a wall in our understanding
where we can't go any further and then
um station low steps in with this book
and he says but there's a reason for
that there's an even darker reason for
that and it's not just that we can't
really get a grasp on it it's like
something is actively trying to block
our understanding of physics and that to
me is just so
freaking terrifying so freaking
terrifying
um so I think the first episode does a
good job of like building up the tension
and really it's hard to kind of even to
be honest to think about these in terms
of like episodes like as Americans you
know see episodes
um because they all kind of just like go
together and continue to weave the same
story I don't know if I could say every
episode has like a solid beginning
middle end it's kind of like it's just
kind of like continuously weaving the
story
um and each episode's just like another
few pages in the book
um
so that's really really good
um I will say
this could have to do with the fact that
because it's 30 episodes and it could
have to do with the fact that you know
they just to put that much money in this
it's not the best
looking television show I've ever seen
but I mean I feel like it looks just as
good as far as like things like CGI and
stuff and stuff like that as like
anything that you'd see on like the WB
or like those um those DC TV shows it
looks as it looks as about as good as
that and when things like that I think
you probably only get like I don't know
how many episodes per season of those
shows do you get like 10 15 here we're
getting 30 episodes so I can definitely
forgive
um CGI that's just like kind of not that
good
James I hope you're like marking down
all the uh super chats for me please
because I'll get to them later I can
definitely forgive all or if not I can
look that up again
um I can forgive the CGI that's not that
good if you know the story is compelling
and I think the story is compelling
if a little bit slow
and she okay see that's I'm running into
the problem that I had earlier because
it's like I think this show is
compelling if you give it a chance right
I could see like a regular person
watching this
if they give it a chance and get through
the first four episodes because I really
feel like the content of the first four
episodes in an American version of this
show would be one episode
like the American version of the show
like the first episode would end with
the projection of the numbers on his eye
right and that doesn't happen until the
fourth episode or fourth or third I
forget exactly which one
um yeah that doesn't happen until
several episodes in and it's so um
someone says still in sync by the way
yeah yeah
um and I feel like that's really the
hooking point in the show and that's
also the hooking point in the book like
once he once he gets the projections on
it on his eyes it's like oh I'm hooked
right but it takes a few episodes to get
into that here and that's just because
it's 30 episodes of one book which is
something we do not see I I have to
emphasize we don't see that in the west
we don't see adaptations like that
you're gonna get 10 episodes to do your
whole book which is crazy
so I have no idea what Netflix is gonna
do but I know that what they're doing
here for me
um is superior to how most adaptations
are handled because like yeah you can
give me like the flashiness of it all
um in a bigger budget but it's like to
me ultimately that all falls short to
the story right because like I don't
care how good and an adaptation is
something is
I don't care how good an adaptation of
something is if they cut out my favorite
scenes right and I feel like here
there's all like the little moments and
scenes like the pool table right the
pool table scene is something that's
probably going to get cut from the David
and Dan version of this but it's here
right it's here and I just I really
really appreciate the fact that it's so
close and so immersive and just like um
they're really really going they they
really they're really going for the book
story right they could have approached
this from like okay yada yada these
books science fiction No One's Gonna
understand that let's change it and
simplify everything
um and basically make it a whole
different story but instead there with
this they're just saying we're gonna
give them the book like I really think
that whoever did the screenplay for this
read the book and just basically beat
for beat it looks like they're just
adapting literally what happens in the
book and I think that's great
someone says Dune in two movies is
perfect right
um it's perfect but I wish I wish we had
the Extended Cut of Dune you know I mean
I wish I really do wish we had that
three hour cut of Doom and then we had
that three hour
um
uh Doom part two right
because I feel like doing is a movie
that needs three hours right I don't
know I haven't seen Avatar way of water
but I hear like at least to some degree
it kind of drags along and not much
happens right
okay back to three body problem what's
great about three body problem this show
is that like
I think that from watching this show
um it looks like I haven't all of it's
not out so I can't 100 judge it but so
far I feel like you could watch this
show and not read the book and as long
as you pay attention to what's happening
it seems like you're gonna get the book
story which is just like phenomenal so I
know like some people just don't read
they have a hard time reading like uh
attention
spans or short and some people are can
watch a show easier than they can read
and that's fine
um I think this is a great opportunity
for someone that wants to get the whole
story but like does it is not
necessarily a reader to like totally get
the story of at least the first book
um and also what's great about
um this release this 10 cent release
is that they're releasing all the
episodes for free it seems like and I
think there's two or three that are out
for free right now and then you can be a
member I'm not sponsored by them by the
way and then you can be a member for
like however much a month
um and then they're releasing an app
they're releasing the episodes daily
for the next like 30 days into like the
middle of February so we're getting the
episodes day by day by day by day which
to me is just like so different from how
everything is done in the western world
it's like you either get it all at once
like a Netflix or you get it like week
by week but to get it daily is so
freaking cool and it's free yeah it's
free I think um the members get the
episodes a little bit earlier
but um they're still releasing the
episodes free which is like awesome
awesome and I think it's really because
the company understood understands that
you know ad Revenue exists on YouTube
you can post something on YouTube and
you get ad Revenue so it's like if
people are watching it yeah so yeah
definitely go I got the link in the
description of this video too so if you
haven't seen it I think like six
episodes are out if you remember in like
three episodes are out or something if
you're not a member uh you can
definitely go click on that watch the
first episode definitely like um
tell them I sent you you know go over
there and be like Quinn's idea sent me
here you know what I mean just do that
do me a little favor that'd be awesome
but yeah so like I was saying I think
episode three or so is the episode
that's really like got that hook moment
when he's taken the photos and he's
seeing the numbers and they're all
popping up it's like what the heck is
going on and and um like I said that was
the part in the book where I was like
okay this is a really really good book
um so in this stream I don't know how
much I should spoil yet
um I think after
um about like five six minutes we're
gonna get into
spoilers for at least book one so I can
talk about like what I saw on the show
like in relation to what happens like
later in the book right so but for now
we're not going to do spoilers for what
happens in the book because it seems
like I think a lot of people are going
to want to enjoy this show episode by
episode and if you haven't read the book
it's like the way it unfolds is so cool
okay and also what's been really awesome
watching this is that I'm also currently
working on
um my next three ready Problem video and
it's very very far on in the series so
it's like watching this show again I'm
like being reminded of like all the
little characters from before the series
like really really expands a lot of
these characters I totally forgot about
a lot of these characters I totally
forgot about which is really funny and
I'm like oh yeah that guy or that girl
like you know you're not like really a
part of this later on because by the
time you get to like the second book in
the third book
so much time passes because it's really
not about like any one character like
Wang is definitely the main character
in the first book but like when it goes
beyond that it's really just about
humanity and like all of these
characters are just proxies for like
just Humanity as a whole you know what I
mean so I think that's um
a really interesting thing about uh the
books as they go on
um so yeah
so before we get into
um the spoilers for like all the
episodes of the show that I've seen on
the spoilers for like the first book
then um I'll just get to some questions
and I'm gonna pull up the super chats
and we'll we'll answer all the super
chats real quick and then we'll get into
spoilers for the show and for book one I
won't spoil anything super crazy but
we're going to talk about like basically
what happens
so let me pull up these super chats I'm
gonna pull up the super chats and I do
that by clicking here and going there we
go there we go
actually before I do the super chats
over on patreon
um um
I told you guys to ask me questions if
you had any questions for the stream
today and so I'm going to answer the
patreon questions first and I'll get to
Super chats and then we'll talk about
spoilers for the show how's that sound
anyway
so someone says any books similar to The
three-body problem
um absolutely yeah okay if you want
books similar to everybody problem you
could do the killing star
um that's by George zabrowski and
Charles Pellegrino as it has a very
similar concept with like the Dark
Forest
um without getting into spoiler so you'd
like that one and I think you'd also
like children of time Adrian Tchaikovsky
um so it has like
that same like kind of like progression
of humanity through like really really
like slim odds
um so yeah I think you'd like those two
if you want like a similar to three
better problem type thing
um someone says have you read the locked
tomb
um or the Texaco Clan series both have
intricate worlds lore and political
Intrigue second what are your thoughts
on the works of
in the or karaf I can never say your
name I'm so bad okora I've never looked
up the pronunciation but you know she is
a Sci-Fi author afrofuturism so I have
not read those
um two series that you mentioned but
Mindy
binti vinti okay I started reading binti
and um yeah you're definitely gonna get
videos about this in the future for me
um I definitely think um
it's kind of like a little bit like you
could you could see the Octavia Butler
in influence on this one especially
because there's like these Medusa aliens
tentacle things and like venti ghosts or
our own transformation so yeah Octavia
Butler so yeah I like I like your work
I'm kind of new to it but it's pretty
good
okay so next question on patreon I'm not
gonna lie when reading I speculated the
first book was an elaborate metaphor for
relations between the nation states of
Earth probably just projecting the
second book made me question the
significance of humanity and the larger
scope but I think the last book kind of
answered that oh yeah good points I
definitely think um
is using several metaphors about
different nations and humanity and I
think a contrary to a lot of people to a
lot of people what a lot of people think
I think this book is actually kind of at
least the American version is kind of
Highly critical
of just like the Chinese government like
the uh
there's there's a particular the aliens
in this series are kind of a direct
metaphor
you know to the Chinese government
it's like pretty obvious so yeah
um and a good point about like the
second book making you doubt the
significance of humanity in the larger
scope because I definitely feel like the
second book in the series is kind of the
one where you're just like oh God we're
kind of specs and then the third book
kind of ends on kind of a higher note
like a little bit more of an optimistic
note so yeah I totally get what you mean
from that all right so that's the few
that's the end of my patreon questions
you can totally check out my patreon
please it's like the best way to support
my channel and we just like redid All
the tears
um we got a lot of stuff happening on
patreon we got like patreon live stream
not only patreons get to we got the
patreon only Discord Channel and you can
get access to that on my patreon link in
the description if you want to support
my Channel please do
um so yeah that was the end of the
patreon questions and so now let's get
to the super chats that I've gotten so
far on this YouTube channel let me look
during the stream during the stream
while I was talking because it's really
hard for me to read the super chats
while I'm talking and then we'll get to
spoilers for the episodes
and for some parts of the book okay
so Lord flannus the flayed anus okay
interesting name congratulations on
getting married how did you and your
partner meet
Modern Love Story on Tinder yep so uh
mackley says love your work looking
clean sir uh I tried the audiobook but
couldn't get past the Chinese names lots
of characters too and I couldn't grasp
it you know you're not the first person
that has told me that like the names
kind of threw them off I mean but I know
that's kind of why I liked it though
it's a little bit more like interesting
and weirder it's like different names
like I like
seeing different names from different
places in the world I think it's pretty
cool it added to it a lot for me and I
think that the book being written by a
Chinese author gave it a feeling that
was distinct from
American books you know like European
books it was definitely like it it was a
different vibe a totally different
feeling and I I really appreciated that
so Archibald fence post says the nerd
Squad salutes you
nerd Squad nerd Squad salute okay
king crab says when will the next three
writer Problem video come out this week
I'm working on it it's super long
um it's about a bunch of different stuff
um the working titles so right now is
the master races of the universe because
I'm talking about I'm trying to mine as
much information as I can about like the
other beings that inhabit the universe
throughout the three body problem books
so I'm trying to gather as much of that
as I can and like it really expand upon
them and try to explain what's going on
with all of them so yeah
okay king crab also love to Super Chat
when will you explain the rest of the
three-body problem series I swear I
thought you said there was one last part
about it
love your work
um even after this video here there's
probably still a lot more to talk about
so there's never there's not really one
last part there's a bunch of little
things and a bunch of big things that
I've just yet to cover because there's
so much
okay so Lord flanis again says love your
work thank you so much uh okay and
that's the last of the super chats for
right now I think
and uh thank you so much Trace face for
your Super Chat as well okay excellent
excellent excellent now
now
begin to talk about the spoilers for the
show I think that if you have not read
the book and you don't exactly know like
the general plot of this this I think
that a few of the things I'll get to the
chat not [ __ ] the chat I'll get to the
chat I can't like talk and look at the
other stuff and look at the chat too but
I think that if you don't know like
where the story is going that a lot of
it might be a little bit confusing
um because they're not really giving you
any indication
when there's flashbacks right because
we're seeing a lot of yangdong we're
seeing a lot of young yeah wenji but
it's all kind of without context
it's all kind of without context James
says one more patreon question sorry I
did not see that
it's kind of all without context I feel
like it can be a little bit jarring if
you don't know where the story is going
so we learned in the beginning that Yang
dong kills herself but we keep seeing
her throughout the show so it's like I
could see it being a little bit
confusing it's like when exactly is this
happening
um so I feel like that's kind of a
little bit of a
yeah okay so last Super Chat Henry
quimbya says Quinn still planning to
create a review of luogi's plan I'm
gonna do a video about Lulu G's plan and
everybody's plan but that's like deep in
the series when we get to the wall faces
and stuff like that so yeah I feel like
the way the show handles flashbacks a
little bit is a little bit jarring and a
little bit weird but that's a minor
thing
um because if you really are paying
attention then I think I think you can
see past that that's another thing about
this show if you are not paying
attention this is not a casual watch TV
show that's one thing we gotta squash
real quick this is not a show that you
can probably recommend to your mom
unless your mom's like really into
sci-fi like real hard sci-fi this isn't
a show that you like recommend to your
mom it is
really philosophical there's a lot of
like really like long drawn-out
conversations like they're like it is in
the book
um it's not necessarily like exciting
Episode by episode and it is a show that
you really really have to watch and pay
attention to to really get what's going
on because there's a lot of like really
interesting subtleties that could like I
think easily go over your head if you
kind of like look away for even like a
little bit of a second
um so yeah it is definitely it's
probably honestly basically like out of
the science fiction shows that I've seen
it's probably one of the most
challenging science fiction shows that
I've seen because it's not like it's not
cutting you any slack it's not cutting
you slack it's like basically keep up
it's keep up you got to keep up or
you're gonna get lost pretty quickly I
would say I would say
um and it's not like um like I said it's
not the American Norm like even when it
comes to more cerebral American
um science fiction
it's not like like this it's not this
level of debt like the best science
fiction movie that you've seen it kind
of pales in comparison to like a science
fiction book
um but this show is kind of like on par
with like the pacing of a book right
because like here's the thing for people
that like don't read books too is that
like when you open a book it's not it's
usually it's not like immediately
extremely exciting like when you open a
book there's a lot of like build up to
get to the stuff that actually is really
exciting
um and you know this show is more akin
to the pacing of a book into the pacing
of a show right so people are saying is
the show I already someone said to me
I'm gonna have to mention every 10
minutes that this is the 10 cent Chinese
adaptation and not the Netflix one which
is later this year
um so yeah keep that in mind and the
tencent one is on YouTube for free but
you can become a member on tencent and
get it early and I'm not a sponsor just
to say again
not a sponsor
um so yeah um I think I think that's one
thing the pacing of the show is one
thing that I think will turn some people
off but for just being a fan that's read
the book and knows where it's going and
just being like a general fan of like
sci-fi storytelling oh for me it's just
just grade like I love all the
conversations of like physics and the
mysteries of the universe and all just
like I I love it I love it I love it I
love it
um okay
what else to talk about what else to
talk about
um with this show
I will say that uh dashu is a little
different than how I imagined him I I
imagine dashu as a little bit older Wang
is basically the character that I
pictured while reading the book so like
he's perfectly cast
um
oh yeah we also got to see uh yeah wenji
I think we got we finally got a
conversation with Yao wenji in episode
four and it was really interesting too
because at this point in the book
you don't really know that much about
yalinji and I remember in this point of
the show you don't really either to be
honest but it's really curious because
you have no idea
that this who this woman is and you just
think oh this is The Grieving mother of
a woman who committed suicide but then
once like I later on when the when the
layers of this character unfolded and
you realize like exactly who she is and
exactly what she has done and the cost
of what she has done to humanity it's
just like oh my God it's incredible
someone says what's the show called it's
called three body and the link is in the
description
um
yeah yeah
is the channel it on for you
someone says is the channel it is free
on here in the description yeah yeah I
I've linked to the place where you can
totally watch it right now yeah yeah oh
yeah okay so it's interesting too they
keep breaking up the turkey scientist in
this and I kind of feel like I could be
wrong but are they bringing it up a
little bit more than in the book
I could be wrong I don't know the turkey
scientist thing is a really really
interesting
and um
scary scary topic and they bring it up
in the show and it was they had this
really neat animation for like the whole
turkey scientist thing so it's like you
picture a civilization
um living on like a flat field and then
you've got like a shooter in another
dimension and the shooter is firing
holes at like every like I don't know 10
centimeters on this like flat plane
where these beings live and so their
scientists come out and they're like
oh a lot of the universe is that there
is a hole in the universe every 10
centimeters so they're mistaking and
unchangeable law of the universe for the
whim of the shooter right it's like the
shooter just did this because he wanted
to it's not a law of the universe but
there's no way for the people on this
flat plane to know it so that's one
scenario for how the universe is
potentially and then the other scenario
is the turkey scientist scenario which
is even more
just just freaky and scary so you just
have like a group of turkeys and every
day at noon the farmer comes and feeds
them and so you get a turkey scientist
and a turkey scientist he observes all
of this happening any and he thinks oh
yeah there's a law of the universe every
day at noon food comes That's the Law of
the universe and then Thanksgiving
happens
and they think oh the food's coming
because that's the law of the universe
and then the farmer comes and Slaughters
all the turkeys right so again the
turkeys mistook what was just like the
what the farmer was doing just like to
feed them and like you know
get them ready for Slaughter as like a
law of the universe so yeah
it's like it's like the we are being
farmed hypothesis which is really really
really really freaky
really really freaky
[Music]
okay
from a zero to ten how dark is the
series well
depends on what you mean by dark I think
the series I think the series is
existential but it's not dark in the
same way that it's not like
depicting a bunch of like messed up
stuff I feel like almost like a song of
ice and fire if you read that series
it's more dark
just like based on like the things that
it depicts like just like the horrible
things but this really what the darkness
in the three body problem books comes
from just like the existential dread of
the concepts that it's introducing
um
so yeah
and and in that and in that for in that
matter I feel like it's like a 10 it's
like like it's like a 10 once you get to
the ultimate like idea of what the Dark
Forest is
you know the idea that like we can't
like the idea that like you know Star
Trek and Star Wars these like
alien civilizations that are interacting
with each other and interacting with
humans and they have a positive
relationship the idea that that's just
not possible at all is yeah it's freaky
it's freaky it's like more terrifying
than like the idea that like we're just
alone in the universe which to me the
idea that we're alone in the universe is
more eerie I think than terrifying it's
just like
wow that's weird like where is
everything how is it possible that we're
the only life that formed it's very very
strange if like we're just alone it's
almost like where we like placed here by
something
just like this vast darkness and we're
the only bubble of reality
we are the only thing that's perceiving
the Universe I think I think that's
creepy Erie yeah for sure someone says
thanks for keeping oh thank you John the
wondering fool thanks for keeping the
good literary conversation alive well
thank you so much for being here
during the Stream
okay
someone says the concept of the Dark
Forest absolutely terrifies me
definitely definitely terrifying
someone says where are you watching this
link in the description everybody Link
in the description
someone says I'm 45 minutes behind but
happy to catch it live best regards from
Texas that's Johnny Campbell hey Johnny
Campbell you'll see this in 45 minutes I
guess
someone says the scariest part of the
books is how we react to the tries to
learn so that's going to be really
interesting to see in this show okay one
thing that I'm very excited for it's
like as The Show Goes On
at the end of the book we get a whole
like section in the book that's from the
perspective of the trislerance so I'm
very very excited to see how this show
depicts the tricolores
um this kid because it could go either
way this could be like really
it could be really bad it could
potentially be really bad because we
don't even in the book we don't even
know what these aliens look like we
don't even know what they look like
so um it'll be curious to see what they
what they show
um okay and I did take notes earlier
because there were some things I wanted
to go back to
yeah yeah so there's a really
interesting thing that the show does
that I love which
um
sometimes when it's showing like
yangdong or it's showing Wang it'll have
like this drone shot it's like oh it's
like something is watching from the sky
and it's like really distorted and weird
that is the so fun if you've read the
book that is 100 the so far
so in the book
the aliens have already crippled that's
why physics is is all screwed up the
aliens have crippled physics
and the so in the sofas are all over
Earth and they're just kind of watching
everything that's 100 the so fun
and it's like Ah that's so freaking cool
that's so freaking cool and one thing
that I like another uh visual choice
that I like that they're doing is that
a lot of the scenes will like start off
by like being like
it'll either like it'll show the
universe and then it'll zoom out and
it'll zoom out into the like atomic
structure of an object in the room and
then it'll zoom out more and then you'll
just be like in reality again and that's
really really interesting because in
later in this book
um and probably later in the show too we
get into a really interesting concept
called um
higher dimensional micro Cosmos not
that's not the that's not what the
concept is called
um
I I don't know how to express the name
of the concept but like we get into the
idea of a higher dimensional microcosmos
right so in the three body problem
Universe
um
when we move to higher Dimensions
everything is more complicated
everything has more space right so if I
was looking at this room from from
within the higher Dimension I would be
able to see
the struck the internal structure of
everything way more spaced out and way
more complicated and as the dimensions
increase that complexity
um expands exponentially so it gets
increasingly more and more complex so at
the end of the first book we see the
process of the trisolarins unfolding a
proton into higher Dimensions right so
if you think about a proton it's one
point it's fundamental fundamental
particle it's one point in space time
right
um but as you move into higher
Dimensions the complexity and the
intricacy of a proton becomes more and
more complex so what ends up happening
is the trisolarians actually
disturb
civilizations living within the proton
in higher dimensions and those
civilizations attempt to defend
themselves it's so mind-blowing and cool
to think that like
there's like a universe within a proton
and that like because of what the
trisolarians were doing they noticed and
they're like oh you're going to destroy
our universe so we've got to defend
ourselves and it's not really clear
whether or not it's like one
civilization or like I think it's like I
think it was likely a group of
civilizations all coming together trying
to defend their Universe from like
basically the tricolores who were about
to destroy it
so that's really cool and I like how in
the show it it's already introducing us
to this concept by like showing like the
zoom in so there's a universe
inside of everything like there's a
universe inside of everything oh like
just the complexity of a proton of a
fundamental particle is just so
so cool
okay
um yes Henry that is absolutely I think
that's in episode two or or one that is
absolutely there and it's a really cool
scene it's an episode two or one I think
yeah so it's a really cool scene
someone says for me the scariest scene
from the book was when the weird
countdown number appeared on the
scientist's eyes yes and that is I think
about episode three or four in the show
and I was saying earlier that I think
probably in the American one that'll be
the end of the first episode but it
takes about three episodes to get to it
here because it's just so much there's
so much that happens in the book up
until that point
um the episodes are about 45 minutes
long
um LED Zepp
so yeah um yeah that's definitely the
hook of the book and that's the hook of
the show for me so I think that if
you're gonna recommend this show to
anybody it has to be someone that you
know is going to like science fiction
like you can't the normies I don't think
the normies are gonna be into this one
but if you really like science fiction
um tell your friend like um watch at
least the first three episodes and if
you're not hooked by the first three
episodes and this is probably not the
thing for you
um and like I was saying before there's
in total about yeah 20 someone's saying
about 22 hours or so of total
um
time in this show 30 episodes so
um I think that's longer than the
audiobook I really think that's longer
than the audiobook so the show is longer
than the audiobook
and um the really interesting thing is
uh the show is
it's really kind of I feel like a a
western thing kind of that our
television shows have gotten so short
because when I was growing up for there
to be like 20 episodes 25 episodes of a
show was normal now it's like
everything's 10 episodes and I feel like
was that what what caused that was that
the Breaking Bad impact was that the
Game of Thrones impact that now
everything's 10 episodes because you
know Star Trek they'd have like 25
episodes per season and that was most
shows right
so I don't I don't know exactly what
changed but um
I like I like getting 30 episodes I like
I like being totally immersed and uh not
having to lose
any of the things that I love about the
book while watching the show I just
think that's I think it's great and um
and I really appreciate the fact that
it doesn't seem like the people that
made this show are putting much of
themselves into it right
um typically when people make
adaptations they have like the Stanley
Kubrick approach where it's like yeah
yeah that's what the source material
says but really I'm just gonna make this
my own thing and it's like kind of
totally different ultimately
um here it's kind of like like I said
earlier it's kind of like whoever did
this screenplay
just basically so far it seems like they
took the book and adapted it as best
they could to screen without with like
minimal changes like minimal changes
there's a few things that are kind of
like a little bit out of place just a
little bit
um
but just I ultimately I think the
changes are minimal which is like it's
really really great
okay
if someone says 30 episodes is great but
it's really hard on the actors yeah I
could see that I could see that
so one thing that I was wondering
um when thinking about the three body
problem show is that I know the three
body problem Netflix show is gonna be a
lot more
Americanized which means we're going to
have a lot more English being spoken
probably there's probably gonna be a lot
more scenes that take place not in China
and I'm just wondering how exactly
they're going to handle that because the
book I mean it's
typically here's the thing I was
thinking about too with a lot of
adaptations of things
it's a lot easier to like take something
that was like you know set in one
country and just like simply move it to
another country but with this story in
particular the fact that it's happening
in China is kind of important it's kind
of a big deal that is happening in China
so it's I'm very
scared
about the Netflix version
I'm very very scared about the Netflix
version because they've just from the
casting alone you can tell like it's a
lot more American and British actors so
it's like we'll see what happens not
saying there aren't American characters
in this show there's definitely there's
already American characters in this show
um but it's like
we'll see we'll we'll see it remains to
be seen
um generally like it's the the consensus
is that D and D
are pretty good at adapting Source
material but like when making their own
stuff that's kind of when they fall
short
someone says will Netflix show the
cultural revolution parts of the book
maybe we'll see
um so far this show has not shown the
cultural revolution parts of the book so
um maybe later on they'll show it or
like hey like I said I I don't
I don't know Chinese so I don't I have
not read the Chinese version of the book
but I heard that part was actually cut
from the Chinese version of the book so
you know I mean Netflix has been bad
about canceling shows that catch on oh
yeah are you telling me Netflix canceled
1899 which was just really upsetting to
me like I have no idea why they canceled
18.99 that was very very upsetting
someone says I can't imagine how they
could reintegrate this cast into a story
and cut the story itself and to condense
Western standards without slaughtering
the original thoughts
I have the same dilemma when thinking
about the David and Dan show I don't
know how you're going to adapt this
story for to be like what an American
audience wants
because I feel like this is a science
fiction book this is a hard science
fiction book to the core and if you're
like a very particular person that likes
hard science fiction then yeah you might
like this show you'll love the book but
do I think that like a regular
just everyday American would turn on
tencent and watch this and like it I
don't I'd probably not I feel like you'd
be very confused by the first episode
and you probably wouldn't get the second
episode and you'd probably lose interest
but then that being said I still have no
idea how you would take the story and
adapt it for an American audience
yeah and not lose something fundamental
about the story and like what it's all
about you would definitely like lose
a lot right because I know they'd want
to like speed it up like I said I think
the first three or four episodes in
tencent will probably be one episode in
the American one
which is like you're gonna we're gonna
miss a lot of the really eerie like
interesting things so it's it's it's
it's kind of hard but I don't know we'll
see we'll see what they do we'll see
what they do maybe they'll swing it just
right maybe they'll swing it just right
and it'll be different I think one thing
you can count on is that it will
certainly be very different
but I think it'll maybe it'll be
watchable maybe like the fundamental
concepts will remain intact but um if
it's really bad then it sucks we'll
always have the 10 cent one yeah you
know there we go
what's it going to be called on Netflix
I think the Netflix one is called free
body problem
or or the three buddy problem whereas
the Chinese one is just called three
body
and the book series is of course the
remembrance of Earth's past
series
these books so you got the first book in
the series
that's
the first 30 episodes of this tencent
show will just be this book and then you
get uh the Dark Forest second book best
book in the series by far in my opinion
and then you've got destined
um the third and longest I believe book
this is the one where where it gets into
the really weird concept this book is
has some of the most interesting and
weirdest stuff
that I've ever read and it's so cool
it's so cool
someone says so neither version is
faithful well no I would say that this
tencent version so far is is very
faithful it's very faithful
to the source material so far yeah
um it just remains to be seen only
six episodes out for members now three
episodes out two or three for everybody
else
um I've seen four of them so far I think
I I'm like excited to watch the other
two tonight if that tells you anything
um generally for me for me I would much
rather have something that just gives me
the book story like as a fan of just
science fiction I like these books like
ultimately when it comes down to it I
like the story that's why I read the
book I don't need it to be changed I
really don't so like ultimately I like
it that was my problem with the
foundation show it was like
I like the foundation books this show is
not the books so why would I like this
show right I don't really like to me the
the foundation books
are great they're philosophical
um they're very slow but that's what
they are
um and they tried to make that show into
like this action-packed like Star Wars
type things and it's what she became it
was Bland it was not what I was into and
It ultimately it failed
um I don't know if they're doing second
season the foundation Maybe
but like with the tencent show I feel
like yeah like I'll be able to go back
and watch this show and enjoy it and I
think I think it's
for me for me it works for me it works
for for other people I don't know maybe
not
so um just let's
um look at the chat and see how many in
the chat right now have you seen any
episodes of the attention show have you
not seen it
when you read the book
and if you have seen it what do you
think about it so far let me know guys
looking at the chat now
I've been looking at chat but yeah
also we're gonna con we're gonna
continue the conversation about three
body after the stream over on Discord so
if you want to join us on Discord like
totally join us on Discord it's a lot of
fun lots of science fiction fans
chatting about different stuff you can
get into contact with me we can chat
about stuff over on Discord Link in the
description
it's a fun place to be and also if
you're a patreon supporter there's like
a patreon only Discord Channel over
there so it's really awesome super sweet
so yeah so someone says only know the
book see I think that um
if you've read the book you'll you'll
like the show
and I think this book I think this show
will be a really interesting experience
for people that just read the book and
they can go right into the show it's
really cool
um there are English subtitles
they're English subtitles
someone says I'm on episodes three one
and three I'm enjoying it very much
someone says see the first six episode
five felt weird a bit tonally I have not
seen episode five yet so we'll see what
that's all about
oh it's my mother-in-law
hey
everyone say hi to my mother-in-law
hello
yes and Carl car snark okay yeah that's
another thing I meant to talk to you
guys about new streaming channels so
we're gonna be talking about basically
every episode
um I'll get on here like like I don't
know like tomorrow or the next day and
we'll stream and talk about every
episode but that's gonna be on my new
streaming Channel Quinn streams Link in
the description so if you wanna
get in on all these streams in the
future they're going to be on that
channel not Quinn's ideas so you
probably want to go to that channel and
hit subscribe hit the Bell do all that
stuff if you want to like get access to
all the streams because we're just going
to be reviewing the show
as it happens so we're all going to be
watching it together reviewing and it's
gonna be fun so yeah click the link on
the description do that and yeah yeah
yeah
so yeah so far
I just have to say like when I when I
realized that that because I feel like
the marketing has been kind of weird I
don't know if just if it's just because
I'm in America maybe it's better in
China
but there was something about the show
supposed to be coming out last year and
then it didn't happen or whatever it's
out now so it's cool but um when I first
saw that there was gonna be
one episode per day
I got so excited because I absolutely
wasn't expecting it and it makes me
I don't know I'm just very happy and
excited to continue watching this show
and to see it unfold
um free body problem has been one of my
favorite books for a really long time
now I've been covering on I've been
covering it on the channel for a really
long time now almost two years I feel
like how long has it been since I put
out that first three body video you
would know better than me you working on
anything now I absolutely am working on
lots of stuff now I'm working on my new
three body Problem video that's coming
out maybe tomorrow maybe
maybe the next day but I have a big
three body Problem video coming out
Master races of the universe which is
about you know the books and stuff that
happens way later on and of course my
graphic novel the LIE behind the star
which you can totally find Link in the
description on my website is launching
this year on Indiegogo we're very
excited about it uh my dear friend
Matthew Weldon is coming back to do the
art for the book and uh that guy is a
genius on another level I'm really
excited about it because it's my first
science fiction graphic novel so that'll
be really fun
which link is dead
I don't know I don't know what link
everyone's talking about
streaming Channel Link Works
yeah so yeah make sure you go subscribe
to my streaming channel to get in on get
in on
all the three body problem stuff
all the reviews
okay let's see let's see what else let's
see what else okay so far like I was
saying uh Joshua
that casting choice is a little bit
weird for me I don't know I just I
pictured Dasha it's just like a little
bit older in my mind
um but so far the casting of everybody
else is pretty good I think Wang is
basically like I said the character that
I imagined in my head when reading the
book so he looks good and yeah wenji
yeah I'm really interested to see like
um more from the actress that plays Yao
inji because she's very interesting
because she kind of has to do like
two different tones right so she kind of
has to like kind of appear as like the
sweet grieving old lady and then later
it's like
yeah wedgie leader of ETO so it's kind
of different so
but so far yeah yeah great casting I
think they like casted everyone well
and two I can tell that like
um the people that adapted this like
science fiction because I feel like when
people don't like the genres that
they're adapting it becomes very obvious
at least to me
um because they the stuff that they
emphasize and the stuff that they think
is important you can tell just based on
the way it's adapted like if you're
watching Game of Thrones you can tell
that the creators really didn't care
about fantasy they really don't like
fantasy that much so they don't really
emphasize the fantasy they cut it all
out kind of but here the science is the
emphasis which I just I think is really
good
I think it's really good that the
science is the end of this emphasis
David Maximo 83
thank you for your Super Chat
wow
so I think
let's see let's see let's see
so s
I wish I could do a poll and get like
what percentage of you guys are watching
the show or have done it I mean I'm
gonna see if I can make a poll
somewhere
what's the best website for doing like
those big those like quick polls
I see other YouTubers doing this all the
time I don't want one where I have to
sign up because I want to pull the straw
poll right that's the one
that's the one have you seen the show
I'm gonna post this poll in the chat and
you guys can go vote and tell me if you
have seen this show
gonna post the poll okay
there you go
so yeah so you guys click on that poll
and I can get a more accurate
um
reading on who's seen the show and who
has that the numbers are coming in the
numbers coming in
okay so far I have seen the show is
definitely winning out
okay
so if I were like we're 80 82 percent
have seen the show 83. it's going up
okay
get out there and vote
so yeah like I said like I said before I
think the show is for two kinds of
people
that maybe you've watched ton of my
videos
so you know what's up with the series
but you haven't read the book I think
you can get into the show maybe you've
read the books and you just want like
adaptation that's like on par with the
books and has the parts of the books
that you like
then I think the show's for you too
so yeah not for normies looks like we're
evening out at about
75 or so
have seen the show
in about 25 have not
so yeah
okay okay so like um you still have time
to watch the show it's going to be on
Netflix so like maybe so hopefully by my
next stream if you want to watch the
show you will you will and like I said
make sure you click the link in the
description to get to uh my new
streaming Channel because that's where
all of my streams will happen
oh wait I'm an idiot I'm an idiot
I can't read so it looks like uh yeah so
only 25 have actually watched it 70
haven't so yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
definitely you guys should definitely go
watch the show like I said if you fit
the criteria for saying this I think a
lot of people don't know about the show
which is why I was saying earlier that I
feel like the marketing has been a
little bit bad because I feel like most
people had no idea it was coming out I
had no idea that was coming up people
told me that it was coming out I'm like
I didn't know that had no idea
so yeah
so yeah the marketing has been kind of
bad I feel like but yeah definitely give
the show a try
um as a major three body problem fan I
think that the show was pretty
respectful to the source but well very
respectful to the source material I
don't know exactly how close is to the
production of the show
um he seems to have like some degree of
influence at least it seems like it
because it's like I said very close to
the book but yeah
yeah yeah
so someone says up to how far has it
been adapted it looks like they're doing
the entire first book over 30 episodes
30 episodes so yeah that is more than
enough time I think to go over all the
nuances and the intricacies of what
happens in the story
all right now so we've been going for an
hour and I think we basically we
thoroughly reviewed the show I think
summarized I think that it's pretty dang
good if you're into hard science fiction
or if you've read the books
um yeah so um thank you guys so much for
watching subscribe to my new streaming
Channel Please Subscribe if you want to
like if you want to catch the other
reviews as The Show Goes On oh what's up
AK
okay I didn't see you there
I didn't see you there but anyway and
also hit the like button on the stream
before you go it just helps out with the
YouTube algorithm if you like uh the
stream
um
thank you guys so much for hanging out
with me and and watching we'll be back
later this week with more YouTube videos
great things to come
um lots of other science fiction things
that I'm getting into too just to give
you a briefing so I think we're going to
be getting into the passage I don't know
if you guys have heard of that trilogy
and I'm blanking on the author's name
right now
the passage
the passage Justin Cronin so that
trilogy we're gonna be getting into that
and then we're going to be getting into
some more Alistair Reynolds for sure uh
more Adrian Tchaikovsky coming up so we
got children of time uh children of Ruin
more stuff on that series and then also
his new book is coming up soon like the
third book in that series ah so yeah we
got a lot of science fiction books uh to
cover I haven't seen the passage TV show
I I don't care to watch the TV show
version of the passage but um yeah so we
got lots of science fiction books to
cover I'm always reading I'm always
trying to expand my knowledge of
you know whatever is out there so I love
you guys uh stay safe be happy and peace
out by the way I'm probably going to
take this video off of this Channel and
upload it to the streaming Channel as
well because I that just seems like
something I should do peace out guys